Teenage Sun has a lot of pain in his feet when he's been on them for an extended period of time.
He wears compression socks and has custom orthotics.
He's seen a diatrist, a pediatric rheumatoid doctor, MRI shows inflammation in his feet.
So I think you're doing the right thing as far as looking for the source of inflammation.
Does this person have juvenile rheumatoid?
You're always digging to the reason why.
So it could be something as simple as falling arches, the arch support.
When I was in high school, I got fitted with these leather type arch supports.
Which I think the hard arch supports are not good.
I think you need a compressible arch support.
I think it was a foot leveler's brain leather arch support.
And boy, that made a giant difference in my inflammation in my feet.
I was an athlete and you just put a lot of pressure on my feet.
As you get older, you have foot pain because you have other things going on.
But as a young adult, you should not...
There's a reason why you have that sort of foot pain that you feel like you have to wear some sort of compression socks or something.
So digging in to find out what that could be looking for autoimmune issues.
Really try to arthritis, gully arthritis, different things like that.
You just have to keep digging and tell you to figure that out.
I can't really give you a whole lot more information without, you know, seed, you know, more details on this history.
I wish I could.
There's just too many possibilities just with that data.